as we continue to look at the homeless
crisis all across the valley tonight 8
news now rode along with a local
Treatment Center to hear from those who
are experiencing homelessness themselves
thanks for staying with us at 11 o'clock
I'm Denise Valdez and I'm Brian Loftus
Madison Kimbrough has reported on the
issue around the valley joins us live
near Vegas stronger on Main Street and
Washington Madison now with more
yeah we've heard about the community
having so many issues with the homeless
population across the valley and tonight
we hear from those living in it as help
from Vegas stronger we traveled to three
different spots this afternoon to see
what they go through
[Music]
it almost doesn't mean that we're bad
Las Vegas Treatment Center Vegas
stronger taking to the streets as 8 news
now joined in to talk to those
experiencing homelessness
focusing on these three main spots where
several homeless encampments are set up
Matt who has been homeless for eight
years showing us where he lives in the
tunnels whether you're trespassing
originally an attorney from Iowa he now
calls this place home and acknowledges
how much his community has grown in just
the last couple of years a lot more
people I've noticed yeah I don't know if
it's because of that but there's just a
lot more of this out here I don't know
the numbers but there's a lot it's hard
to find a spot or a place that we can go
Matt has been living in this particular
spot for over a year but says it's
usually a constant moving game we're not
supposed to be as law enforcement local
arrested for trespass and they often do
or the city comes down there about twice
a month and they bulldozed everything
and they take it and oftentimes they
take you know the good stuff and
that really happens Vegas stronger
handing out supplies the center
specializes in substance abuse disorders
and Mental Illness but the majority of
people suffering from some type of
addiction
like Joseph who has been living on the
streets for 20 years after moving away
from his home in the midwest you see a
lot of stuff people don't realize it
really goes on it's messed up but it's
become live being from Oklahoma
drugs are uh
frowned upon by most people especially
weed
so
yeah I just like that lifestyle
now that admitted it's kind of like a
mundane both men want to get help but
admit the fear of change is what keeps
them homeless well I'm used to it but I
want to get out yeah absolutely
yeah I don't think anybody down here
really loves it down like this I think
that's the problem I've grown
comfortable with it
and Vegas stronger making weekly trips
out to these encampments with the hope
of reaching those who are willing to
take the help reporting live Madison
Kimbrough 8 News Now